robert spencer you wrote about a bizarre
study at the university of california
berkeley that discovered that women are
not being oppressed by the systemic and
institutionalized misogyny of islamic
law i.e sharia which basically makes a
woman a second-class citizen denies her
rights testimonial rights inheritance
rights and so on says it's okay for them
to be beaten but women are suppressed by
islamophobia
can you explain that
well it's just more academic nonsense
the
academic
establishment just like the political
and media establishment is committed to
whitewashing islam and making sure that
nobody thinks that there's anything
wrong
with islamic teaching or islamic law and
so you have this obviously misogynistic
law
that discriminates against women in
numerous ways as you enumerated just
some of them and the
researchers are trying to turn this on
its head and say oh no really it's it's
it's islamophobia that hurts women's
rights it's patently absurd and nobody
who knows the reality of women's rights
in sharia cultures could possibly take
it seriously but we're talking about
academia we're talking about uc berkeley
we're not talking about something we
should take seriously